as part of our eye on America series we
are getting an inside look at the fight
against a major suspect contributing to
the u.s. drug epidemic the Drug
Enforcement Administration says the drug
lord known as el men show is one of its
top targets the u.s. is offering get
this ten million dollars for information
leading to his arrest Adriana Diaz is in
Chicago one of the many cities where
neighborhoods have been hit very hard by
a massive flow of drugs they drown oh
good morning what are you learning good
morning well standing along i-29 T in
Chicago this is also known locally as
the heroin Highway that's because this
is the road many drug users take to come
into the city and buy drugs last year
alone in Chicago nearly eight hundred
people died from drug overdoses and the
DEA took us inside neighborhoods were
many drug deals go down sirens are part
of the soundtrack in pockets of
Chicago's West Side the DEA is Brian
McKnight took us there to see the drug
trade up close she comes right now
that's where we saw an ambulance
responding to a suspected overdose we
were in unmarked cars but the locals
knew better it's not happiness was
shutting down his business for the day
we did spot a sale nearby where several
people entered an alley to buy drugs
there's literally a line now everyone's
coming about guys see the guys put in
got his right hand he's putting his
pocket what percentage of drugs in
Chicago do you think come from Mexico
a significant amount probably about you
know 90% 90% the arrests of notorious
Mexican drug lord el chapo guzman has
done little to stem the flow of drugs
into the u.s. that's because a rival
kingpin has forced his way into the void
nemecio Segura Cervantes don't simply as
el mentos the DEA says his cartel called
cartel Jalisco or CJ and G is
responsible for roughly a third of the
drugs entering this country by land and
by sea you do know one priority for you
know for DEA and federal law enforcement
United States Matthew Donahue was the
DA's top agent in Mexico and has helped
uncover dozens of al menos drug labs in
the jungle el mentos used to live in
california where he was arrested at 19
and deported back to Mexico that's where
his drug empire grew by force he once
shot down a Mexican army helicopter and
was suspected in this public hanging
this summer is he the most brutal cartel
leader that you've come across he's
definitely one of them his group
definitely does some of the worst
murderous and revengeful things that
we've seen against innocent human beings
back in Chicago the Mexican drug seized
are so toxic
they can't be handled without protective
gear and at the DA's lab packs of
cocaine are stamped with traffickers
brands agents are now seizing potent
mixes of heroin and fentanyl it's a
daily occurrence that needs to be
stopped
says acting DEA administrator Oh Tom
Dylan their drug trafficking baguette
some violence on the streets poverty
anguish throughout the entire country
the aftermath is unmistakable this
Chicago man survived this overdose but
last year more than 67,000 Americans did
not while most drugs come from Mexico
the DEA says that many cartels are
getting their ingredients for opioids
from China meanwhile mentos is so
powerful the agency says in part because
he has entire police departments in
Mexico on his payroll and that makes it
even harder to cap
Anthony Adriana Diaz with the ongoing
war on drugs Adriana thank you